please don't suck please don't suck
please don't suck Ralph Rex the Internet
well um it didn't suck I do kind of
wonder if I should have wished for
something with a higher bar to clear
that than that though so oh boy
where do we start with this one okay let
me first be very upfront in
acknowledging the fact that I went in
not expecting to enjoy this
I have Wow I have either disliked or
hated most of the marketing material
that's come out in support of this film
I am relieved to report that a lot of
the stuff that even at the time that I
did my reviews of those teasers and
trailers that I kind of put an asterisk
on and said it's possible that this is
being created to look this way
specifically for the trailer and it's
not indicative of the way the film goes
a number of those one was where I said
that about that turned out to in fact be
the case I think the easiest case in
point is when they are talking to the
search engine and you know vanellope is
like what's a website that's like
totally awesome and crazy and then he
directs them to Disney yeah that doesn't
happen that was it was cut together a
look that way for the purposes of the
trailer so some of them some of the most
egregious stuff that goes on in the
trailers is not in the film the thing
that I hated absolutely the most out of
anything else on the trailers is in the
film in a way that actually really
ticked me off because it wasn't in the
film proper and I thought oh good they
cut better of it and cut it and then it
was the mid credit thing with the
leading of mom they didn't have a scene
in that movie that was in the trailer I
didn't like that and then they showed
the thing that I
it's so much ah like I don't feel I get
this boiler to see what scene that is
cuz it wasn't a trailer but no it's not
a spoiler so I'm gonna say this thing
with the kid to like a three year old
playing a game and it's the bunny in the
and the Katniss the pancake and that
thing blows up and the kid screams like
childhood traumas not funny plate me I
hate that I I hated that in the trailer
and I like movie ended and I thought oh
it's not in there and then it was in the
MiG oh okay
try and get your try and get to a more
positive place I will have complaints I
will have net pics I I don't think I can
help
having this review I mean that moment
aside because I hate it I don't mean for
this overall review to come across as
negative as it's probably gonna end up
being but ultimately I can't help but do
well on what it is that keeps this from
being as good as the first one and
that's probably what I'm gonna spend the
most time talking about that should not
be taken as an indication that the
movies terrible it's not as I said it
doesn't suck so and there's a lot of
stuff that is in there that is kind of
smart and kind of clever some little
moments some bigger ideas it just
doesn't all quite come together in the
way that the first one did I will
however also point out I took my
daughter she loved it she thought it was
great she says she likes it a little bit
more than the first one and when I asked
her why her I mean she's at an age where
it's not always easy for her to to nail
down why she likes something she just
knows that she does but you know what
she said was she liked how much stuff
there was so I think she liked the
greater variety of settings of
characters of situations versus the
first one because the first one was
primarily I mean the biggest chunk of it
is just set in candy crush but even
beyond that it's not a ton of locations
in the original you know it's Ralph's
game it's a little bit of time and the
in the station between games it's a tiny
bit of time in hero's duty and then
other than that is pretty much all in
sugar rush so you know it
this offers a much greater variety of
set pieces and of characters and of bits
it's it's not to the point of being like
oh god they won't do one thing is saying
one place it you know it's not it
doesn't have that sort of a beedi effect
so I get why that appeal door and again
she liked it a lot so when it comes to
will your kids kids like it but yeah
probably don't worry too much about that
so where do we go with this from here
all right I want to try and stay
positive for as long as I can and which
means that I'm probably not gonna talk
too much at the front end about Ralph
himself because a lot of my issues stem
from him not that he is poorly portrayed
or even necessarily poorly written it's
just the direction they chose to go with
him which is not it's not like it
doesn't make sense I just feel like
while it's a certain to a certain degree
and natural progression to the character
it's something that feels very played
out in general and I can't really talk
about that without getting spoilers and
again I'm trying to stay positive I mean
general though I still like his vibe but
you know in the chemistry between Ralph
and vanellope that still works we get
some very cool new characters the big
one being shank voiced by gal gadot who
is a racer in what looks to be a sort of
GTA online sort of game and so she's
very cool and vanellope immediately is
looking up to her massively because you
know really cool kick butt lady racer in
this crazy insane game so yeah that's
that's cool and that also lends probably
the best action sequence which is some
of the racing stuff that goes on there
the actual sort of visualization in
general of the internet is pretty good
actually it's pretty neat it's not my
favorite I think that'll probably still
go to Oz from summer Wars but it is it
is very cool it's very neatly done I
also want to point out that like unlike
say the emoji movie while this does
site-specific real world websites by and
large anything that is truly plot
relevant with the exception of Disney's
own site but Disney owns it whatever the
the things that are truly plot relevant
are not real-world sites so there's a
chunk
the things spent not on YouTube but on
Buzz - I think Buzz even as threesies
you know they don't they don't search
through Google they search through knows
more so that you know I do appreciate
that and initially part of me was like I
kinda wish they weren't referencing the
real names at all but then I think about
it like you know what that's not as big
a detriment as like I we tend to think
cuz I mean yeah at the time that I
watched it was kind of oddly quaint
seeing Blade Runner with you know big
things for like Atari and and you know
coca-cola and what and whatnot but the
thing was is that at the time the film
was made those were contemporary you
know sizable companies so there's no
reason that that actually has to date it
specifically so like the present but
literally just an image of Google
Twitter snapchat whatever don't care
it's again it's not emoji movie levels
it's not like we're going to stop and
explain how this website works and don't
you wish you could spend time with this
thing that we basically stopped and did
a complete sponsorship for it's
absolutely not that I've seen more than
a few reviews basis say it's like the
emoji movie was good and that's not an
accurate but I do feel like it's
shortchanging this movie because that
the whole thing that the emoji we got
bogged down in which was highlighting
all these specific apps and junk that's
just this movie just doesn't do that it
spends time in programs and websites
that means something to the plot but if
it doesn't have a useful plot they don't
stop there for more than like a quick
visual gag so yeah duh all that was fine
pretty well thought out All Things
Considered eBay gets a bit of a
highlight but you know for again for how
the plot is going to move forward it's
actually a reason that it would be eBay
so like that's fine so all of that works
pretty well the there are some
interesting there's some interesting
sort of theming in terms of where the
relationship between Ralph and vanellope
is that again I don't
is a bad call in and of itself but I'll
come back to why it's it kind of
kneecaps the thing overall but I'm down
with the choices that were made in
principle I just yeah I'll get to that
the Disney Princesses actually they do
get more than just that one scene that
was in the trailer and the sort of
seeing vanellope integrate with them was
kind of cool they picked on Ariel a
little bit more than I would have liked
but that I'm biased I really loved the
Little Mermaid but I I say picked on her
they weren't unfair and they weren't
really unfair to any of them and the the
princess is actually do get a little bit
more than just that one scene including
some really neat sort of ways in which
they are visualized and come together
and things like that so actually I died
they were used better than I thought
they would be as far as marketing
marketing goes and they even get a
little bit of mileage out of some of the
other Disney stuff that they own they it
was a really cool place Minerva of a
Wilhelm scream for instance and I won't
spoil how that joke works but that that
I quite liked I think though I need to I
need to start moving on to some of the
things that again I don't want to say
these don't work because they do but I
just got to start it's William so this
is where it's kind of start to get into
spoilers it's not bad if I no means
ruins the previous movie if you have
little kids they'll probably love it and
if you're not as nitpicky and
over-analytical as I am you'll probably
like it more than I did
there you go consider that a
recommendation for a movie that I myself
don't feel that I am or need to see
again where does that might be so
getting into spoilers now okay so a
major theme for the first one this is a
theme that connects for me in general I
mean if you've seen anything like the
list I did of ten movies that always
make me cry which the original wreck-it
Ralph was actually my number one on that
spot a big thing for me that always
connects with me is people making
connections more specifically people who
think that they can't connect with
others that managing to do that
and that it was really in many ways the
through line with route that had a lot
of things going on in terms of relating
to other people finding ways to relate
to people but also coming to terms with
yourself and everything kind of fed into
that theming because you have Ralph who
knows his place in the world but is
resentful of it because he doesn't like
being the bad guy anymore
you have vanellope who doesn't know her
place in the world because she knows
what she feels like she is which is a
racer but that world won't welcome her
so she's sort of at a loss because she
knows what she thinks she is but it's
it's not working that way and then as
the villain in that you have turbo who
is somebody who has decided he's going
to reshape the world to force it to be
what he wants it to be so that he can
have the role he wants rather than
taking any sort of acceptance of what
his place is he said no I will literally
break the world in order to have the
hold the position that I want to hold so
everything about it your two main
characters your primary conflict the way
the world was threatened in your village
all fed into this common theme and that
sort of unifying central core isn't
really here in in ralph breaks the
internet it's not totally absent of
theming but that's part of where I'm
gonna come back to something I talked
about earlier so the main thing that
things move ahead on is they are leading
much more heavily they use the term best
friends but in terms of the matically
it's very clear that they are leaning
very heavily on Ralph and vanellope as a
father/daughter relationship and that's
made and that's not me projecting that's
like made explicit at a number of points
like to the point that it's singled out
that you know Ralph is doing dad humour
um you know they they point out that you
know they've been friends now for six
years and that's kind of a significant
number because what happens when kids
become six years old they start going to
school they start going to first grade
now I mean you know your kids will go to
kindergarten but not before that but
really first grade feels like a big deal
and that does often feel like the point
of which you are sort of losing them a
little bit and Ralph's having now been
with vanellope for six years feels like
she is drifting
away from him and he has put on an awful
lot of stock and an awful lot of his
sense of self into this relationship
that he has with her which is also a
thing that parents tend to do with their
kids it's part of what having your kid
grow up to and start to do their own
thing whether it be school meeting
friends that you know maybe are not what
you idealize as being that your child's
future or going off to college or what
have you
a lot of that sort of pressure in those
sorts of weights are laid on to Ralph
and like I said it's it makes sense in
terms of a progression for the way Ralph
sort of relationship and his character
flaws work the problem though is is that
this is much more well-trodden ground
especially in animation because the way
in which this ultimately manifests are
the things mistakes and stupid things
that Ralph does trying to ensure that
vanellope doesn't leave in other words
you know to stretch out the metaphor
trying to control his daughter figure
and this is really really well worn
ground in well in films in general and
animation especially it you know you can
go back to things like The Little
Mermaid I may love it but you know that
that is what kicks off everything going
downhill as a father trying to control
his daughters future that is basically
the entire through-line of the Hotel
Transylvania series and there's a whole
bunch of others I'm not coming up with
them off the top my head but like this
is not new territory so that that's an
unfortunate thing where even though they
took Ralph in a direction that is
logical and is consistent that
unfortunately puts him in a place where
thumb Attica Lee what's going on is not
nearly as unique as what was happening
in the previous film or at least it felt
much more unique to me in the previous
film because of the the combination of
self-acceptance and and acceptance from
other people and the way that all folded
together here we're getting a narrative
where a father figure goes oh my god I'm
gonna lose
my daughter and then does something
really stupid and really just not nice
to try and force her to stay with him
and that's a again that is not new
especially lately like it really feels
like in the last few years that that's
been that's been hammered on a lot so
that that doesn't help and then you know
like I said you can look at the at the
villain of the first moon you can look
at turbo and I know a lot of people are
very over the whole sort of hidden
villain thing that animated films Disney
especially has been doing lately
I do think turbo is one of the better
executed ones of those though because it
is highly thematic overall to what's
going on
in terms of why he operates the way that
he does and you know that he is sort of
the extreme version of what is the worst
thing that Ralph could become in his
effort to you know want to say he gets
to be what he wants to be and to go from
that where he's combating what is a you
know fully formed character to where
outbreaks the internet where he is very
literally fighting a monster made of his
own anxieties it's only clunky it's a
little on the nose and while it doesn't
seem to bother my daughter I can't help
but think that that big Ralph's anxiety
monster is going to be literal nightmare
fuel for a lot of kids it's it's
actually really unsettling it kind of a
cool idea but like I don't know dude and
the other and but that's another thing
is that this movie kind of has to pull a
tangible threat for the climax kind of
out of its butt because up to that point
if ting gears for what it for what the
story it's telling is because initially
we are looking at well the you know the
characters are settling into a routine
and vanilla peas a little restless okay
that's our starting point Ralph tries to
help and then break stuff
annoying and also a little bit
repetitive given what happened with him
in the in the first film but okay now
vanellope x' game is in jeopardy oh okay
a little bit of a retread but okay
that's how we get to the Internet
trying to find a way to get the things
we need to fix the game so she doesn't
lose a game she herself says she wants
to save the game that she doesn't want
it to go away but then she finds
something new so now it's a clash
between ralphing you know being able to
let her go
and then literally because Ralph decides
to be the most deliberately selfish I
think that he's ever been like knowingly
selfish he decides to unleash this virus
so that we can have a physical threat in
the climax and it really does feel like
a bit of a hard right turn it doesn't
come completely out of nowhere but it
really does feel something she warned in
for the sake of a more traditional
climax because I mean again - compared
to the first movie you look at like the
side bugs the sidewalks get established
fairly early into the film and then the
the threat of them and the fact that
they are still around we get a couple of
reminders across the film so when they
erupt at the end even if it's been
awhile since we've seen him you go oh
crap that's right
and now we have to deal with that
whereas here the virus literally gets
introduced over an hour into the film
there was no hint of any sort of real of
a physical tangible threat the threats
were been for lack of a better term more
existential for the most part they were
about this relationship and you know
about the idea of is bunnelby going to
have a home there were more abstract
threats and then like two-thirds of the
way into the movie the final boss threat
gets introduced out of nowhere basically
so you know and again I it also bothers
me how much Ralph backpedals it doesn't
feel like it completely undoes his
character growth from the first film and
it's handled well enough that it's not a
completely regression it doesn't feel
like they recommed his development but
there is something irritating to me on a
personal level that I really do think
that he acts way more self
here than he did in the original film
because in the original film he acts
selfishly but he gets tunnel vision on
what he wants and doesn't really seem to
well he just doesn't stop and think
about what the consequences to other
people will be once he realizes what
they are he starts to realign what he's
doing here he makes a choice where he
knows that she is not gonna like him for
doing this and that is potentially very
dangerous and does it anyway that like
that's a that's a new level of selfish
for him and again I get it like
fanatically I get it you know the
lengths that it feels like some parents
go to in an effort to keep their
children close to them but you know it's
it's it's just it's just frustrating for
me overall and that's kind of the the
viewing experience of this in a nutshell
I kept seeing things that I'm like
that's a good idea
that's a good way to handle that and
then seeing other things that I'm like
yeah so you know it's a mix in a balance
and again if you're not as overly
analytical as I am if you're able to
sort of turn your brain off a bit more
than be and you know just sort of have
the experience watch over you it's not a
bad experience it's not a bad viewing
experience and it's a fairly fun movie I
just you know I can't I can't stop my
brain from comparing it to the first and
seeing the ways in which it's not as
consistent coherent and as well layered
as the first film was so I mean that's
it for me I I don't this strikes me as
the kind of opinion that I that there's
gonna be a decent amount of commas you
know telling me how I completely misread
the situation or I got it wrong or that
I read way too much into it which you
know fair but is what it is so Ralph
breaks the Internet have you seen it
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff you can do because there's
buttons in
links and you can you know go places and
do things like go to my page around
support me there if you feel like doing
so if you don't don't worry other links
you can check out don't want to look at
them that's fine too because at the end
of the day folks
you're the council I just from the
meetings and until next time this
council is it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]